dorium put a full circle last streisand
she also visited the center yes yes that
that was incredible
I mean I I think I held my breath for
ten minutes while she was there I mean
she is lovely and you know she's just an
incredible woman and that the truth is
is throughout her whole career she
really had a hand in every single detail
and I really admired that about her and
when she came on said she was so lovely
and oh yeah warm to all of us and she
washed a little bit of the you know
earlier edits of the film and it was it
was spectacular and we've got a great
picture of the two of you together it's
like diva squared Oh was that before
that's before before yes that's the
first time you met her right yeah we had
had dinner together at her house yeah of
course you had
I mean because how does this story
resonate with you
Lady gaga because you didn't to be a
star from very little I how old are you
in this this looks like someone
pretending is my attempt at Michelle
Pfeiffer yeah how old are you I think I
must be 10 it doesn't it looks like a
lady Gaga impersonator it looks like a
girl I'm being Lady Gaga for Halloween
usual to be Lady Gaga young stars how
old are you here Bradlee shave the beard
off of years off me
I don't know I think it was my birthday
I think maybe three or something how
does the picture get out in the world
how do we know what my mom sends
pictures out all there's a great picture
this is Jodie Jodie Whittaker I don't
know when this was
wait were you going for an 80s pop star
look I think here you are oh joy skies
it's a poncho
okay quite Seaford that but I've got
tips and they match the pink strike I'm
up toast yes you can see I love it
hey-oh I mean it was the alarm so I was
I was just method we you like a really
young aerobics instructor don't take it
away from me
Ryan you do have a connection I've got a
weird intro to show business via would
you your uncle I believe yeah that's
right
so he was your uncle living with you yes
did you walk into the room once I walked
into the room once and he was be
dazzling a sequined white jumpsuit and
and he said that he was gonna be Elvis
for a little while and and you know what
I'd like to help what do you need me to
do so I became his head of security and
he got my whole family in on the act my
mother was a backup singer and honestly
it was one of the greatest performances
I've ever seen no no he yeah he I mean
what I admired about what he was doing
was that he looked nothing like Elvis
you know he didn't attempt to he had a
mustache and very little hair but my god
he just he just became him and you know
he would end every show with suspicious
minds and he would get on his knees and
and and often with tears in his eyes he
would he would sing to some imaginary
woman and beg her not to leave and we
were transported from this mall in my
small town in Ontario to to to that I
imagine it was a kitchen and she was
trying to leave and we were just in that
moment every night and it was it was
incredible and and and honestly one of
the best like acting lessons I've ever
I was gonna popped out with those
sequins use a little I would have liked
that
how old were you at when you were doing
security I want to say six quiet let's
add two tiny guns space there's no photo
no I think I painted a picture of Riley
yeah
[Music]
you